[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في جبينه ندبه من ضربه عسكريين
له باخمص البندقيه كان ذلك في مظاهره وهو
يحاول تسلق سور السفاره الفرنسيه في بيروت
احتجاجا على اعتقال وتاذيب جميله بوحيرد
وقد قيم بها وحزن كثيرا حين وصله خبر
زواجها وتحطمت الصوره المثاليه التي كانت
في ذهنه عنها بعد ذلك والسؤال كم من الصور
المثاليه التي سقطت وتحطمت في اذهاننا
جميعا اتحدث لكم وانا من الاجيال الاخيره
التي عاشت الاحلام القوميه والوحدويه
واليساريه في اعمالها المتعلقه بالوحده
العربيه والاداله الاجتماعيه وغيرها من
الشعارات التي سقطت تحت دير الواقع العربي
ضيفي في الحلقه السابقه وهذه الحلقه دكتور
فواز طرابلسي واحد من اهم الشخصيات
السياسيه والفكريه في هذه العوالم عالم
الفكر والسياسه والاسار والثوره واهم
انجازه كان الكتابه والتاليف في هذا الحقل
اضافه للترجمات الهامه التي قدمها الاعمال
العالميه لانجلز وجرامشي ولينين وتروتسكي
وتشي جيفارا وانتهان بادوار سعيد لتصله
حاصلته في الترجمه الى 19 كتابا اضافه
لانتاجه الخاص من الكتب والذي اشر له في
الحلقه السابقه معه اناقش المراحل
التاريخيه الهامه التي عاشها العرب في
القرن العشرين وكيف ادت منها كل تلك
التفاعلات لمثل هذه النتائج التي نعيشها
اليوم واصل به للربيع العربي والثورات
التي شكلت في مطلع ايامها حلما عربيا في
عالم العداله والمساواه والديمقراطيه ثم
ما لبست ان انتهت لمنتهت عليه ان كانت قد
انتهت بالفعل وكما يقال دائما لا يمكنك
التنبؤ بالمستقبل دون فهم وعن والدقيق
وموضوع التاريخ الدكتور فواز طرابلس كاتبه
المؤرخ لبناني واي في المقابله في الحلقه
الثانيه فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
في اي اسره نشات اعرف انه كان الوالد يعمل
في سوريا فتره ثم عاد عمل ايضا في مجال
الدباغه ثم في فندق خاص للعائله وما الى
ذلك الوقت
[موسيقى]
ضد الاداره وهي اداره بريطانيه بس الاهم
الحدث الاساسي كان 56 عدوان السويس والاثر
الثاني كان همم ثوره الجزائريه
بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
انا ذكرت لك انه يعني نسبيا كانت بدايه
عمليه بدايه الكتابه متاخر بدات بالكتابه
والترجمه ايضا
ترجمه قديمه قديمه مترجمه بالسبعينات
ترجمه كثير ترجمه
كثير عن
الحركه الشيوعيه ترجمتها
ترجمتها
عفوا ادوار السعيد العلاقه
[موسيقى]
كانت
احدى زياراته وهو يعد كتاب
خارج المكان
[موسيقى]
بقصد التعريب يقصد انه القارئ يقرا النص
وكانه عم يقرا نقص كتاب نص مترجم مكتوب
باللغه العربيه الاصلي اللي هو يعني عمليه
صراع زي ما بدك بين اللغه الاصليه وبين
اللغه العربيه لازم اللغه العربيه تتفوق
على اللغه الاصليه
وبالتالي يعني
والا النتيجه بتكون انه في نص انجليزي
موجود يعني منقول للعربي
ترجمه خارج المكان
ااا قال الله يرحمه ويسامح ادريس شو اسم
نسميه خارج السرب وهو افضل هو كان في فكره
انه نسميها كان ياما كان خارج كان يا مكان
كان لا مكان كان لا مكان ثم راحت صارت
خارج المكان
[موسيقى]
اول الصور الصوره الشهيره
بالنسبه لاجور لانه طبعا نحن نزلنا بطريقه
يعني كان بده يزور الجنوب بعد التحرير
بعد التحرير وكنا على صله يعني انا بسكر
يوم التحرير كنت عم بكتب له ايميلات عم
بقول له شو عم بيصير وكان جدا معجب
بس وقت
الاستاذ حبيب فاضي
وقال بدنا نروح
بوابه
يعني
برج اسرائي
واب يعني التحدث وبنته
اذا بدك
ترمي حجر انا معك وكمان رفيق يعني من
المقاومه
وكان في صحفيين يعني
ادوارد عارف انه موجود يعني
في التلفزيون تبع حزب الله
فطبعا كان لها نحن بالنسبه لنا كان عمل
يعني
مش موجود كان الجندي يعني مكان مداوي
اسرائيل تمام وانا استغربت انه في عدد من
المثقفين يعني لبنانيين انه مش عارف
الواحد
الصهيونيه بامريكا
وازعجته الحقيقه
انما طبعا تجاوزه طبعا عندك صوره شهيره
ايضا مع عرفات ياسر عرفات في الافلام
الحرب اللبنانيه حصار بيروت
الاسرائيليه ما اجى على مركز
للشبيبه منظمه العمل
وبتذكر يعني عاش الايام
[موسيقى]
في محاولات يا انزال هليكوب هليكوبترنه
طيران ومحاولات قصف بالطيران وبالتالي كان
دائما
الحركه بسياره وقتها لان كان في قصف همم
يعني للصدفه كنا بمركز شباب
هو يعني ونزلنا كان في مستودع سجاد قعد
فيه بلاش اتصالات بس الصوره
احد كبار مترجم
[موسيقى]
ومهما وفكريا ونوعيا ايضا ترجمات الاولى
ال ال ال الاعلام الفكر بشكل عام كيف كان
اثرها في الساحه الثقافيه والسياسيه
العربيه هو كان في طلب يعني مدهش بتلك
الفتره يعني الستينات والسبعينات
والسبعينات عالم يعني كثير خاص من الفوران
الفوري ومن الشباب المقدمه على ومن
انتصارات حركه التحرر يعني يعني في العالم
كله العالم كله وبالتالي كانت يعني نماذج
لحركه الاحتجاج
بالعربي كان في طلب شديد يعني كان من
الصدفه انه يعني في في ناشر استثنائي اسمه
الدكتور بشير الدعوه اللي هو كان عمليه
بحزب البعد بس يعني حضرنا ان احنا مجموعه
مثقفين تبع لبنان الاشتراك
واحمد بيضون
كانوا مترجمين وكان جزء منها
وكان شديد الانفتاح على ما نقترح عليه بس
يعني كان هذه يعني فتره بعد بشوف ناس يعني
بيقولوا لي قرينا لك ترجمه يعني انا جاي
بالطياره للصف المواطن لبناني صاحب بنك
بيصير اليوم مصري
فعلا ايه في العراق احتفوا فيك صدام حسين
كان بيقرا ترجمتك الشهيره في ايه في حادثه
رؤيه لي من صديقين
وحقيقه اللي قابلتهم مرتين صدام حسين
سالني بطريقه ملفته عن ترجمه
لكن الرئيس
بعد رئاسه
احتفالات 14 تموز
كنا نروح وفوت حركه الوطنيه ما قبلنا مره
اختاره ان يدعونا انا ورفيق نادين عبد
الصمد
ف عطانا فكره يعني
ستكتسب اهميه بعدين
حول تصور
اذا بدك يجيبه بوليتيكي له ولباس وهو قال
وقت انه نحن كنا جايين ندافع عن المعارضه
السوريه انه ليش النظام العراقي مبسائد
معارض السوريه
احنا جايين نحامي على المعارض السوريه انه
ليش ما بيساعدوني كفايه لانه طبعا كنا
صرنا تحت ال ال
الانتداب السوريين
والاتجاه الثاني سوريا
وقال انه الاتجاه
نحو السعوديه وذكر لنا انه نحن اااه
ثانيه بلد نفطي من حيث الاحتياط
وتضل سعودي الاول
ثم من سوريا نحن يعني نعمل على التغيير
بسوريا انما بما معناه انه نبحث عن ظباط
مؤهلين وليس مجرد حركات شعبيه
[موسيقى]
فهد اللقاء اعطانا فيك اعطاني فكره حول
يعني حرب الخليج حول يعني كل فكره الكويت
ثم
يتحدث بهذا الاتجاه هذه ذاكرتي يعني ما
فيها
التباساطر
[موسيقى]
بسوريا قال السعوديه
المنافسه اذا حيتبددوا ثروتهم نحن نكون
البلد الاول
على الاتحاد السوفيتي
العراق بما فيه كفايه
ما دخل بخلاف مع الحزب الشيوعي العراقي
والحديث
نجيب بس يعني تقصد انه يجيب اثنين شيوعيين
يلتقي معهم دون وفد في شيء 87
سالني بالاول شو اخر ترجمه
كل الوقت معارض يعني
البعث يعني
بمجله الحريه يعني حتى وقته كانت كاتب بقى
ليت
ضدهم بانه يعني كان نظام ايد ايد حزب
الكتيب
وهو فعلا يعني على حساب الحركه الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
كان له تاثير صدام حسين في في اوساط
اليسار في بيروت في لبنان
بفتره الحركه الوطنيه على دعمه وقت يعني
دخل الجيش السوري على لبنان
ويعني موال حركه الوطنيه
يعني بمقدار مكان دفاع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالحركه الوطنيه
يفترض يعني معارضه الوجود في العسكري
والسياسي
وهو الدعم كان من هذه الزاويه
[موسيقى]
لم تقدم هذه القيادات المستندات بشكل
الرئيسي
الناتجه من رحم ثورات عربيه
بشكل عام اذا ما عرضنا الحديث عن الخلاصات
الدكتور
لا بعدين يعني
نحن امام يعني نكبه كبيره
اسمها انظمه الاستبداد
اللي هي متعدده انما اذا بنحكي عن ما
يتعلق بانظمه الاستبداد الناجحه حركه
التحرر
نحصد النتائج يعني انهيار الدوله
[موسيقى]
النتائج النتائج احتلال العراق
وما انتجته يعني واستدراج استدراج يعني
التدخل الايراني
تدمير الدوله طبعا يعني
دمرت الدوله العراقيه بواسطه
الاحتلال
الامريكي
[موسيقى]
لتقويه المجتمع المدني
اضعاف الدوله ادى يعني خروج الشياطين يعني
العائليه والطائفيه والمذهبيه
[موسيقى]
15 عاما من هي الفتره التي استغرقتها
الحرب الاهليه اللبنانيه مخلفه نحو 200
الف قتيل فضلا عن عشرات الالاف من
المصابين والمهجرين توزعت عوامل الحرب
الدمويه على شقين داخلي تسيدته الطائفيه
الى جانب بعض الاختلالات البنيويه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وخارجي تمحور حول
القضيه الفلسطينيه والكفاح المسلح وخطر
التوقيت مثل مقتل احد مرافق رئيس حزب
الكتائب هي النجمين الشراره التي اوقد نار
الحرب في الثالث عشر من ابريل عام 75 ردت
عناصر الحزب المسيحي باطلاق النار باتجاه
حافله كانت تقل فلسطينيين ما ادى الى مقتل
في يونيو من العام التالي طلب الرئيس
اللبناني سليمان فرنجيه من دمشق التدخل
لحمايه المسيحيين فدخلت القوات السوريه
ومكنت الميليشيات المتحالفه معها من قتل
اعداد كبيره من الفلسطينيين وبعد اقل من
عامين وتحديدا في مارس عام 78 غزت القوات
الاسرائيليه جنوب لبنان تحت ذريعه اساله
قواعد منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه وايشائن
منطقه عازله
استمرت رحل معارك طويله قبل ان توقع
غالبيه الاحزاب اللبنانيه المتقاتله عام
89 في السعوديه وثيقه اتفاق الطائف التي
اوقفت عجله الحرب الاهليه اللبنانيه في
اطار تفاهم عربي غربي
ومصالح اطراف وجهات محليه
واقليميه ودوليه
تاريخ لبنان الحديث كان عملا في غايه ال
ال ال الاهميه الرغطه فيه لبنان من من من
من من كونها اماره في الدوله العثمانيه
حتى اتفاق الطائف لبنان وكانه
قدره ان يكون منكوبا دائما
هل تم استثناء في يعني ماذا وجدت في قراءه
المعمه والموسع التاريخ كانه في استثناء
تتويج دراسات طويله
همم حولها لكتاب
ليس بدون قصد لانه يعني بعد اتفاق الطائف
كان فيه اعاده نظر
بفكره الكتاب المدرسي مكان عندي هم اطلاقا
من لازم يكون في كتاب مدرسي موحد انما
تدرس يعني تاريخ لبنان ومن خلال
المحاضراتي يعني قلت خليني يعني اكتب هذا
التاريخ
بس الاساسي بالغرض كان امرين واحد انه
يكتب تاريخ اقتصادي
اجتماعي سياسي وثقافي والكتاب
اثنين انه اعطي حجم كبير بهذا الكتاب
لمقدمات الحرب والحرب يعني الكتاب في اربع
فصول عن الحرب واحد 64 70 الثاني
مختلفه للحرب
تعتبر ان الحرب كنايه عن مسار له منطقه
وبالتالي الصمت يعني الفصول الثلاثه حول
من هم المتخاصمون منهم المتقاتلون على شو
عم بيختلفوا وكيف انتهت يعني المراحل في
75 77 ثم تبدا 77
82 يعني انه يوقتها تدخل خارجي
ثم الجيش الاسرائيلي ثم المرحله
[موسيقى]
الهيئات اقتصاديه
تمام طرق تجاره تهريب حشيش مرافق استيراد
سيارات
مصادره مصادره دوله همم بالمعاملات العامه
ومقدمه لما حدث لما يشهد اليوم
يعني مثلا امل حزب الله كان حديثا امل
كانت قديمه لكن كلها تفاعلت فيها الفتره
هذه
فقط
للسيطره على الطائف حركتها
الحرب انتهت عندما كان الصراع هو من يفوز
بحدانيه السيطره على الطائف يعني
سمير جعجع والياسمين
يعني كل فكره الطائف لازم توحد بظل قائد
عسكري ونفس الشيء القتال بين بين حزب الله
وامل شرس جدا كان في ما في مشكله سنيه
غريبه
[موسيقى]
واخرجت ثانيا من القتال
حزب التقدم الاشتراك وحركه امل اقصد لماذا
لم ينشئ ظرف موضوعي ولاده همم
الشيعيه او المسيحيه
السؤال مهم بعتقد الجواب بالتقريب على هو
انه مصدر القوه اللي اجى للسنه كان يعني
رفيق الحريري
بالتالي اجت قوه اقتصاديه سياسيه مرعيه من
قبل الامريكان والعربيه السعوديه بحيث انه
يعني
اخل او او كل التسويه كانت بالطائف في
زياده
موقع ودور الوزاره ورئيسها بوجه رئيس
الجمهوريه فبتالي هذه جاء متاخرا وجاء
بصفته ممثل يعني ما بعد الحرب انما يعني
هذا الوزن ما كان بحاجه لان القوه عسكريه
لكن لاحقا تم اكتشاف الحاجه له
بدون بدون نتائج عظيمه طبعا لانه بعد
غيابه اصبح وكان السنه بدون رعايه في ظل
مجتمع من الشيخ
هذا هذه الحاله الاقطاعيه الطائفيه يا
دكتور كانها قدر لبنان انا ما بسميها
اخطائي رايك نحن نعيش في نظام
راسمالي نظام راس مالي اصلا تاريخا هو
النظام راس ماليبرالي
كل شيء صار انه جاره تعديله بظل اعاده
الاعمار بحيث انه جرى تنميه قطاع المصرف
والعقاري
وان يعني
اكثريه اللبنانيين بيشتغلوا بنشاطات لها
علاقه بالخدمات وهي نشاط اقتصادي
وبالتالي بقايا الاقطاع اللي كانوا لهم
سلطه السياسيه قبل الحرب بعد موجودين يعني
عندنا قصر ثاني
السلطه السياسيه سلطه الاحزاب كاينه احزاب
مسلحه لا تزال ضمه
اذا ما فهمنا شيء ما بفهم شيء كثير
بالنسبه
الطائفيه لها عده وظائف
بس همم
منها يعني هذا هذا
التغطيه هذه على نظام من الفساد والافساد
انا سميته مافيوي لانه قائم على يعني
انتاج المصالح الاقتصاديه من خلال القوه
او الجيش فانت عندك يعني تكوين تمام جديد
الاقتصاد اللبناني نتج عن عهد
الاعمار وهو اولا المجتمع الاستهلاك نحن
نستوردنا يعني كل الاستقرار طبعا النظام
يعني اعاده الاعمار بنى على ثوره عقاريه
فاصمه كبير من اللبنانيين وهم اكتريتهم
ملاك صغار باعوا اراضيهم نزلوا على المدن
اااه
جرى تثبيت سعر العمله بحيث انه صار ما في
اسهل من يعني حد قدنا من
الحياه الاستهلاكيه واجت البنوك اللي عاد
رسمتها
بواسطه مديونيه الدوله رفيق الحريري انا
بعاد يعني انتهت الحرب والنظام المصرفي
على الارض ما في شيء كان في رسمي الاجنبيه
عربيه غادرت من خلال مديونيه الدوله يعيد
بناء هذا النظام يعني
وفور عقاريه هذا هذا نظام معقد اااه
على راسه على راسه احزاب الان وقاضي
الاحزاب همم
اشكال الولاء
يستدرجونها همم بالطائف وبدونه يعني
الاستقرار هذا النظام بيقول له اعلان في
طبقه وسطى واسعه بتبين كانه ما قالها
علاقه فوق الوسطى تنتخب
بهذه القيادات يعني هذا الفكره بانه في
شيء شواذ
بالتالي نمط الاحتجاج
حقيقي وشعبي انما ال ال يعني تضييع
الموضوع بطبيعه النظام رايي كله يمنع تصور
انه في سلطه سياسيه وفي سلطه اقتصاديه
تندمجان بطريقه ملفت جدا جدا جدا
لا تنتهي لكن لبنان ما في انفجار في
الدنيا ما حدث فيه انفجار داخل
اشكاليات كبرى لا يمكن ان نتوقع انفجار في
وجه هذا النظام القائم النظام الطائفي
وهذه التسويه التي همم يعني تعتبر تسويه
غير عاديه في حق اللبناني
اولا الانفجار حصل
يعني حصلت للدورات من الانفجارات 2011
2015 2019
عما جرى في كل
الماسهم الربيع العربي
جزريه باي مكان مش لي مش اللي تبرير همم
في لبنان فقط
بمحل انكسر
الوضع بواسطه عندما انكسر الجيش يعني
انتهيناز
بلا ثوار
يمكن مدخل افضل ايه
لربطه بالربيع العربي طيب بمعنى انه كل
حالات الاحتجاج التي حدثت في العالم
العربي انت برايك انا لم تفضي الى تغيير
حقيقي
انا رايي اولا يعني في فرق بين المعلن
والحقيقه بمعنيان وقت كتبت الثورات بلا
ثوار بلا ثوريين المقصود انه
هذه اول انتفاضات شعبيه ضد
العولمه
واثر على طبقات الوسطى والشباب والطبخات
الشعبيه
الاجتماعيه فبتالي هذا تشخيص الاسباب ما
بدي طول تشخيص الاسباب وبالتالي تشخيص
للمطالب للبرنامج انما كان في مفارقه ضخمه
بان هذا الاعلان وبين وعي
انه ثلاثه مشاكل رئيسيه العمل
والديمقراطي ومقدار من العداله الاجتماعيه
راحت نحو تنظيم يعني انتفاضات ضد السلطه
السلطه
هذه الانتفاضات من البدايه كان في سياسه
امريكيه واضحه حول
كيف يحافظ عليها الانظمه مع تغيير
شكله
وهي انه يستبدل يعني الرئيس بنائبه وهذا
ما حصل على الاقل بالاول بمصر
هلا بس بالحل ثاني الجيش كان وراء
التغيير
لم يحدث
لم يحصل بسوريا لسبب انه لو حصل بسوريا
نقل نائب الرئيس محل الرئيس كان في تغيير
بطبيعه السلطه يعني
بس
الانكسار
هو عندما عسكري
الفورات مش حكما عليا بس القول بانه في
يعني
اداره وهي اداره ارادت ان تدعم كمال
الانظمه التي تراها الولايات المتحده في
يعني مصادره خارجيه هذا واحد اثنين
والافضح هو انه اخذ انا رايي الحركات
الجماهيريه اللي معظمها عفوي
عبرت عن المناخات الموجوده حاليا لاسمه ضد
السلط طويل بس في نقطه الموقف الامريكي
وسماح بتغيير جزء لماذا لم يحدث هذا الامر
مثلا في سوريا
سببها كتير بسيطه هو نجاح النظام بانه
يقدم نفسه انه يقاتل ضد
الارهاب الدوله
السياسات
تاخر يعني ثلاث اربع سنوات بعد الثورات
ثلاث سنوات في الفتره الاولى الامور حدثت
سريع في اليمن
انا اذا اذا بتابع كان هناك برنامج تغيير
بانه في ثلاثه
مناصب من السلطه قابله لان تغير
مهند الثلاثه اللي قضى عليهم بالانفجار
تبع
قيد القطريين انفجار تبع خليه الازم كان
في مشروع بدائي وكان في مشروع انه النائب
يكون بديل ونحط على جنب هذا
قدره النظام بان يبطش شيء وانه الولايات
المتحده كان عندها برنامج للتغيير
[موسيقى]
بدون نتائج حتى
حتى بدا بدا
النساء السوريه
عاده بيصيب كل العالم بس انه هو الماسات
انما بدا استدراك استدراج التدخل الخارجي
ايران وبروسيا روسيا وجيشه
وتركيا وبالتالي انت امام يعني صاروا
الامريكي صار الدوري الامريكي العسكري هو
حمايه شريط الشمال الشرقي اللي هو الاكراد
او المناطق المسيطر عليها
سرعه تدخل الخارجي
ولا مره كان في برنامج واضح اسمه لكن في
تدخل اسرائيلي
في شعور انه يعني
لسنا معنيين
بهذه الثوره ولا حتى ولا حتى وقد باتت تحت
سيطره تنظيم الجهاديه اساميهم مثل هندي
يعني الاسم الاكبر يعني من الثوار
الاصليين يعني نزاح وبدات يعني التنظيمات
جهاديه متعدده الولاءات والارتباطات
هيدا هيدا يعني
كان الشواذ اذا بدك بالتدخل الامريكي
الرضائي لانه معظم الحالات هذه تمت
بالاتفاق يعني جاري الاتفاق سعودي ااه
امريكي وخليجي حاول تغيير علي عبد الله
صالح
في في رئيس هرب وفي رئيس يعني ازيح بواسطه
للاضاءه ما تبقى هي برايي نقاط الضعف بان
جذريه ما انتجت هذه الجزريه القضاء اللي
انتجت الثورات البطاله الخصاصه
قائمه اليوم بشكل اشد على سبيل المثال في
مصر
فكره انه كل تازهم بوضع بنت الثورات
تازم بالوضع ممكن ينتج احتجاجات تاجر تاذن
بالرضع ممكن ينتج انتفاضات بس انه اذا
المقصود بكلمه ثورات في جده وهي حركات
شعبيه تغير نظام اجتماعي واقتصادي
والسياسي بالقوه
تمام
الحكم وهي قوى قادره انه يعني تقلب النظام
بوسيل من الوسائل
بالاحتجاج الشعب الدائري
تمام
[موسيقى]
موقف انه قبل اليسار في العالم العربي من
الثورات والاحتجاجات اللي حدثت في عام
معظمها كان معها يعني كان في خانه
الاستبداد او في دعم الاستبداد او في
التواضع مع الاستبداد او في تبرير وفهم
الاستبداد كل منها ما كان في الصف الثامن
هذا
الحالي الشعبي كانت فرصه لليسار بانه
يستخدم ما لديه من جهاز نظري وفكري وتجاري
بتوليد الفكر بقول نحن بمرحله جديده هل
المرحله الجديده هي التالي وهي تفترض
اشكال تمام مختلفه من النظام
يرجع يجدد صلته بخواد الاجتماعيه
يعني انا مش معجب يعني قصه الشارع كمان
يعني
[موسيقى]
فكره اسم الشارع
وصار صار صار ينوب عن همم تنظيم فبالتالي
ثورات بلا تنظيم اصلاح بلا تنظيمه
فبالتالي يعني الافتراض بانه
تعقد المشكلات الاجتماعيه بذاته بيعمل
تغيير بيعمل احتجاج طيب
لانه لماذا غاب عن هذا الدور اليسر
اوكي
الاسلاميين كان عندهم قراءتهم بما يجري
ااا وليس
بوجه قراءه ثانيه انا يعني بحط اليسار ضمن
المعسكر اسمه جماعه الدوله المدنيه يعني
انشق هذا التيار الشعب الهارم بين تيارين
واحد منظم له رؤيه كامله تبدا يعني كيف
تحصل
بالصلاه انت هيك بتروح الجنه الاسلاميه
هذا اللي هنقوله ثورات بلا ثو- ثوار هذه
الرؤيه البديله لرؤيه اللي استلمت الحكم
اه ضعيفه
في حالات كثيره انه نحنا مع الطرف الاخر
بكل يعني هذا اللي حصل انه مع الطرف اللي
هو المستبد الذي كان يصارع يمكن يمكن
انتقاد شديد لتيارات همم مختلفه ضمن
[موسيقى]
الثورات نسميها الثورات هل لي ساعدت على
يعني
ضرب الاسلاميين هذا اذا رايي العمل
ديمقراطيه عمل ديمقراطيه انتخابيه بمصر اه
كان لازم الدفاع عنه بغض النظر انها في
هذه
الاسلامي هذا ما حك النجاح انك تقدر
تقاومهم وتبني نفوذ عليهم
مصر وقد انشق اليسار القوميين والعلمانيين
كل السبب الحالتين
وبمصر المؤلف المؤلم هو الى اي مدى اجرى
يعني
تغليب العداء للاسلاميه على ال ال ماهوئات
ومعلن اسمه وهو عم يسمي شكل جديد من من
الاستبداد هذا
فرصه
الديمقراطيه الانتخابيه بالبلده ما كان
لازم تفوتها بس بيعطيك فكره الى اي مدى
هذه الفرصه تتهدد ان ساعات ناعات ضد
الديمقراطيين بالبلدان طيب استمرار الحديث
عن الربيع العربي والاحتجاج والغضب كثير
يعني من يحاول ان يفسر كل هذا التراجع
العربي
هل تعتقد انه هذا
همم ذلك الشكل من النشاه التي كانت على
الدوله العربيه الحديثه والتقسيم هو يقف
حجر عثر اساسي امام اي مشروع انها ضوي
حقيقي في العالم العربي اولا ساكت بكم ما
قالوا عليها بالاوضاع الموجوده سايكس بيكو
يعني خرائط خريطه المنطقه الحاليه لم ترسم
رسم خريطه
الاتراك هذا في اسم مستعار في شيء بيكون
هي حاول تقسيم المنطقه
سكس بيكو هو يعني السيطره على
الولايات العربيه المشرقيه
بواسطه والتقاسم الفرنسي البريطاني
التقاسم تم بواسطه نخب عربيه في الاول
اسمه الاستعمار الجديد وكان تجربتهم وكان
راي الفرنساوي الانجليزي ما فينا ندفع
فلوس لنخلي القوات
التحكم بدنا نحكم بواسطه
محلي فلسطين
وعالم الانتماء العربي
على على مستوى القيادات وبالتالي كل حكم
محلي كان بنفس الوقت يستخدم الدعوه
العربيه للسيطره المحليه
ويريد ان يتمدد خارج حدود ولا يعمل شيء لا
داخليا ولا خارجيا بالتالي ايه صحيح
عدم القدره على الاحاطه بالقطر بتنوعه
والدليل انفجار يعني تناقضاته وهذا الشيء
اللي الان يعني الاخوان بالمعارضه السوريه
متنوعه كانت يعني تحت حكم البعث باسم
العروبي مسيطر عليها اه يعني موحده بالقصر
اه
بيكتشفوا الاكراد مثلا
اللي هو عدم ادراك همم مبكر للمساله
الطائفيه
الدعوه العربيه تحولت الى تمدد قطره يعني
الى همم مشروع الفيلالي اول ما دخل على
لبنان حافظ الاسد مشروع فيراني
وصار البحث انه بتوافق عليه ولا ما بتوافق
عليه طلب من كمال جنبلاط ان ياخد موقف هذا
واحد توسع زكاه لك اياه حول تصور ال ال
الحاكم الباسي العراقي همم
التمدد ان انا عراقي عندي امكانيات نفطيه
بيتمدد نحو السعوديه بيتمدد نحو سوريا
سوريا
بديلا عن بناء
اشكال مختلفه متدرجه من
الاتحاد
المشترك يعني اول الجامعه العربيه ضربت
اثنين ولا مره يعني انكسر شيء انه هذه
الاخطار كل قطر مربوط بطرف خارجي اه
اقتصاديه وسافيه
التالي يتم على حساب العلاقات الداخليه في
ما بيننا فانت انت امام موضوع تمام مختلف
شكرا جزيلا الدكتور فواز طلبي الشكر ما
وصلكم مشاهدينا الكرام القاكم ان شاء الله
في الحلقه القادمه دمتم بخير وفي امان
الله
[موسيقى]